good morning everybody
hope you are having a fabulous day
you are plugging into a stock live
my name is rebecca dukes kozak and i
will be your host for the next two hours
of this amazing resource that we have
put together
offering you
options that you're not going to hear
about anywhere else
we just want to make sure
oops sorry
i did have it turned off
um anyways
back to the show hello and welcome to
ask doc live my name is rebecca dukes
kozak i will be your host for the next
two hours of this
program that we are bringing to you as a
resource to get information on how you
yourself can be the authority of your
own health and take your health back
so no matter where you are in life no
matter where you are in the united
states or the world
you have options
and in our program we will be sharing
options
to help you on a better health journey
now if somebody invited you to this
program
make sure that you get back with them
and let them know how much you
appreciated that they took the time to
share this program with you
we do have our website askdoclive.com
which is the host of this program
but we want to make sure that the person
that shared us with you
knows how much you appreciate it so
they'll probably have a way that they
um
if you hear about any of the products
today that you want to get started on
they will have a way to help you get
started on those so please get back with
them
now i do have to let you know that the
content of this program is to provide
educational information only on the
importance of nutrition through
we say supplementation in some areas we
say essential factors and others you
make the choice what you want to use
because our food supply it is null and
void of those factors that are essential
to our body
and with that being the case
we are barely surviving folks unless we
are intentional and what we put into our
bodies what we keep out of our bodies
that
we need to be able to thrive
so in this program we will be sharing
nutritional options
that are available to fill those gaps
through supplementation in a form that
the body can actually utilize
because they are readily available now
the fda does require us to let you know
that our products are not meant to treat
prevent diagnose or cure any disease and
this program is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician
our good doctor dr joel wallick has been
instrumental in suiting the fda with the
nine victories
and these victories have all led to the
addition of vital nutrients added to
foods both for adults and babies
allowing the distribution
of this information that has been proven
by
science people it is factual
in the essential need
of what our body needs to protect us
against disease
so
we also want to make sure that you know
that the genetic theory
has been proven incorrect there's a
science called epigenetics epigenetics
is the study of how
our behaviors yours and mine
and the environment can cause the
changes in the way that our genes work
and with epigenetics that makes you even
more empowered as an individual
in the ability to take
control of your own health journey so we
invite you to feel the difference with
the options that are going to be shared
in this program
and any type of testimonial that comes
on
has
totally voluntarily
brought to you by the person that is
sharing it we do not solicit solicit
people to do
or even share their testimonies but
those that do we just want to thank you
for stepping up and sharing with us how
well you are doing on your health
journey
now to guide us we are honored to have
the one and only who is one of the
founding fathers of the study of
epigenetics here to share the best
options to obtain or maintain
optimal health but before i introduce
him
if you are on live with us make sure
that you turn that chat option on
our co-hosts nassema omar jonty
mccollier ruth ellen sanchez dr judy
reynolds and heather
bowen will be sharing information in the
chat that's going to help you
be able to know exactly what dr wallace
is talking about the products how you
spell them
where you can go to find additional
information and of course the reminder
to get back with the person that shared
this program with you
if you would like to ask a question of
dr wallach
here live with us
go to that zoom menu
and find the reactions where you can
raise your hand i will be calling on
people in the order that their hands are
raised so everybody sit back make sure
you've got your drink full
add some minerals in there because
you're in for a great show
dr wallach
i know you've been doing a lot of
research share with us today and welcome
to ask doc live
well thank you so much for all the kind
words and introduction rebecca beautiful
job as usual
and i'm very very excited because you
introduced me to a story uh that's in
the press in australia i'm going to be
on
with australia tonight on a zoom and so
i'm going to give them kind of the same
monologues we're doing here now
and
this
woman doctor by the name of dr
carmel
harrington
my heart goes out to her because her son
died of
sediment death syndrome sids some 29
years ago and she set off on a
thing to find out what caused sids and
sentiments because she felt guilty
back then you know doctors say well the
mothers are laying on the babies and
suffocating them causing some death
syndrome
and that was the the um
letter of the day back then 29 30 40 50
years ago
and so i'll start there and so i began
to just because i'm the guy that figured
out the cause
and prevention
of cinema death syndrome
in 1977.
okay that's a little while ago in 1977 i
was working at the yerkes primate center
um
as a pathologist
for uh
nasa okay at emory university in atlanta
georgia
and ran into the first non-human case of
cystic fibrosis a terrible birth defect
and i
um
sent slides out to about a half a dozen
different medical schools
in america
but i didn't tell us from a monkey i
just said you know here's some lungs
some livers some pancreas i think this
is cystic fibrosis so what do you think
and they all wrote back on their
letterhead you know we're talking 1977
and they said yeah this is a classic
example of cystic fibrosis then i told
was from a monkey and i said at the very
least we have at least an animal model
now
um okay and i got permission was because
they had such wonderful letters back to
me i got permission to do biopsies on
the other 24 baby monkeys in the colony
and they all have cystic fibrosis it
turns out that the behavior is okay
um there
um
let's see here
a couple uh two behaviors of husband and
wife
okay um
uh
it's um trying to remember his first
name it'll come to me in a minute but
her name was nelly
uh born
okay jeffrey what's his name jeffrey and
nelly born and
um they were angry with me because you
know all these monkeys uh were on monkey
pellets and they're plucking their hair
and these well they don't get enough to
do so they took away the monkey pellets
without telling anybody else and just
gave them bananas and squash and
that kind of stuff and um that's why all
the babies had scissors roses because
the mothers didn't have all the
nutrition that were in the monkey
pellets because they didn't have monkey
pellets anymore
and
anyway the reason why i had that job i i
had done a big project
between
1967 and 1977
at washington university at the center
for the college of natural systems i was
a pathologist i did 20 000 autopsies in
ten years seventeen thousand some change
of over 450 species of zoo animals and
three thousand humans and the purpose of
that study nih 25 million bucks center
for the college of natural system
washington university in st louis um
barry commenter was ahead of that in
marlon perkins mutual mahal kingdom show
i was in africa working on the white
rhino conservation project and he pulled
me back to be the pathologist on that
project because i'm the guy
that wrote the first
uh story on and scientific paper on a
mass die off from pollution so they
wanted me because the purpose of the
study
was to find a species of animals in the
zoos and the big cities of the world
they were sensitive to the same
pollution that humans were just like um
the coal miners used to take canaries
down in the mines so if the gases would
leak into the mine the canaries would
die first and men do to get out and so
we wanted an early warning system in the
zoos of the world so since i wrote the
first paper on a mass tie off in america
from pollution they picked me to be a
pathologist okay so that's how that all
happened to you why you wallet okay well
that's why
okay
now uh my
um thesis which is 5000 pages
was published as a book
in
1983 by wb saunders which was the
biggest
medical textbook publishing house in the
world
the books sold
again the disease of exotic animals
for twenty five thousand dollars each
you can buy them today used and beat up
really badly if they're beat up really
badly the cover is torn off and all kind
of stuff they go for say fifteen hundred
it's um three thousand dollars each if
they're in fair condition they go from
three thousand to six thousand dollars
each they're in good condition they go
from six thousand to ten thousand
dollars each after that you gotta pay
twenty five thousand thirty five
thousand dollars new in the box still
wrapped up never opened
okay
and um very very proud of that work and
of course that goes into sudden death
syndrome so 1983
and then
um
dr milan and i went to china in kishon
university heilum zhong province
because they had a disease there called
ketone disease
thousands of kids were dying
every month okay from this keyshawn
disease which is hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy heart disease that's a
disease that
causes sudden death in our young
athletes today
and so dr milan and i went there we did
1 700 autopsies
um
all the biochemistry all the slides uh
all the background
and got it published
in 19 let's see here
uh 1990.
now back in 1990 the rate of
of sentiment death
syndrome
was a 130 to 150 per hundred thousand
live births
okay
and that amounted to about maybe 3 000 a
year in the united states
um and so it's one of those things where
uh it is very very obvious because
keyshawn disease was hypertrophy
cardiomyopathy heart disease and some of
these of course
um
well all of them 1 700
were kids under the age of 10 in
heilongjiang province so it was quite a
study and of course our co-authors in
the original paper
uh were like five chinese
um professors there and so dr milan and
myself and elite authors and then these
five chinese professors so this is this
is a big international
study and um now today
and since i went and started tracking
this today the rate of sudden death
syndrome
is 15 to 20 per hundred thousand live
bursts that's a lot different than 130
500 40 160. okay went down 90 why did it
go down 90 well as as rebecca said
we sued the the um fda
and the manufacturers of baby farmers
like 12 times in federal courts we won
nine times
and forced
the um manufacturers of infant mill
simulac and all the other baby farmers
to put these nutrients in there
particularly the mineral selenium
selenium deficiency that causes
uh cystic fibrosis musculosphere and
sediment death syndrome
okay
and so of course you have all these
other decisions that go along with it
and give you all these variations but
the basic underlying cause is a selenium
deficiency
and so once they put that in there the
death rate
from sediment death syndrome dropped
in 1990 from 135 to 160 per hundred
thousand live births down to 15 to 20
per a hundred thousand live births so
why is there still 15 to 20. that's
because
some mothers are eating gluten and
breastfeeding the babies and they're not
taking supplements and so the babies are
not getting the selenium
they die of sids or maybe they're just
giving them cow's milk without doing any
other
vitamins and minerals
and um are pet milk out of a can
and they're dying of sids okay but if
they do everything right there won't be
any more babies to have sids
now
as a result of all this the guy who
discovered that selenium was an
essential nutrient required for life
with dr gerhard strauss a great great
great phd guy
um from california just a great guy
uh he uh helped me get an award
called the klaus schwartz award which i
received in in 2011 klaus schwartz award
very very proud of that
and um
uh
uh all because dr gerhard schrouzer knew
i knew what i was talking about
and then
i also got an award uh the united
nations
in 2000 in august of
it's a lifetime achievement award on
natural medicine lifetime achievement
award from natural medicine um
and here's a picture of me
at the headquarters of the united
nations in
um
new york city okay getting
this award
okay
i'm very very proud of that
this is again the lifetime achievement
award
for natural medicine
by the united nations
he only give out like one every couple
of years or so
okay very very proud of that
that was 2015.
now the reason i'm sharing all that with
you
is because
we're sending this information to this
lady doctor
dr
carmel harrington to let her know that i
discovered all this in 19
um 77
okay and so she's not the one who's
discovered anything
she suffered a lot because she lost her
son 29 years ago
and we we love her and so forth but i
don't want her spending
um money that should be spent on other
things
um trying to prove her theory
okay because she's way off way way off
on that one
and so
um
it's it's not that i'm bragging here but
i'm sharing all these awards with you
showing
that other scientists and universities
the united nations recognized that had
made these discoveries
okay
and so
and as rebecca said
i'm the guy myself and one other person
a behaviorist
okay
he and i are considered the two founders
of the science of of epigenetics and of
course my book
the disease of exotic animals was sold
for twenty five thousand dollars each
the average person's not gonna get that
they have a home remedy book to cost
twenty five thousand bucks so he
summarized it this is three hundred
pages out of the five thousand pages
three hundred pages epigenetics
and it goes into the same diseases
but it only costs i think 25 bucks if
you buy 10 of them you get a big
discount on each one of them
and um so it's one of those oh there i
am with one of my monkeys from this
yerkes primate center
in atlanta georgia where i did that
study
okay
on uh cystic fibrosis and that's where i
first discovered that uh you know babies
would die of hypertrophy cardio heart
disease called
sediment death syndrome in 19
yeah there you go in 19
um
uh let's see here
um 77
1977.
and so it's one of those things where
i have left a trail
of publications and awards so
dr
carmel harrington
cannot
which i say diss
my comments because i'm the one with the
awards and the papers
um
okay
100 scientific papers
and 21 books i got another book coming
out here pretty quick
i'm very excited about that
it'll be a very unique book a very
unique book because the last
segment of the book
is ten
um of my zooms with a pharmacist
over the past three years and each one
of those cds one of the there's each one
of those 10 cds
is an hour long on a specific subject
heart disease
diabetes
cancer
arthritis
excuse me birth defects
and so there's 10 of those cds it's
going to be in the last segment
of the book
going into all of these terrible
diseases that are just simple
nutritional deficiencies there are no
let me repeat
there are no genetically transmitted
diseases of any kind there are no
autoimmune diseases of any kind and if
you have a doctor who says oh this is
autoimmune disease i can just you know
relieve your symptoms but you'll have
this forever go get another opinion from
somebody else get one of our books
and of course
mr rebecca is going to give you a way
you can get get the books and so forth
and cds and dvds so you can get the
information yourself okay back over to
you rebecca
all right dr wellick you definitely have
left a trail of books
tuna is documented and published of
course we've got epigenetics
rare earth forbidden cures
one of the most famous ones dead doctors
don't lie written in how many different
languages well the cd is in nine
languages okay two chinese languages
okay mandarin cantonese it's in korean
it's in french it's in german it's an
italian it's in canadian as well
[Laughter]
okay
i'm kidding of course
[Laughter]
and um uh and so
um
it's just very exciting uh oh it's in
korean uh and so forth sold 600 million
copies of that cd
nine
nine different languages very very proud
of that and of course it's all in your
head that's the one that you and i we're
kind of working on now
to fill that out
we
i believe that
the osteoporosis of the skull which
produces 25 different diseases
is the same disease as ms multiple
sclerosis
okay as when you start looking that you
know all the diseases and all the
symptoms that are recorded for ms
multiple sclerosis they're the same
diseases and symptoms that are recorded
in osteoporosis of the skull so i'm
merging the two diseases
and the thing that got me going on that
was about a month ago now uh the us
government put out a news release
that
um we're spending each year in america
through insurance payments
each year
85 billion dollars for just in just for
pharmaceuticals to relieve the symptoms
of ms
just to relieve the symptoms of ms 85
billion with a b dollars that freaked me
out and i looked it up and sure enough
that was true
and so they're not treating these
patients with ms
to
get rid of it to cure it they're
treating them
um
to just relieve the symptoms which makes
the patient initially happy but they
still die too much early and there's
clues everybody with ms everybody with
um
osteoporosis skull has celiac disease
which is a gluten issue can't absorb
nutrition
as you're eating gluten gluten gluten
gluten gluten
because your doctors say eat more whole
grains well that's wrong okay and then
um also
uh it's one of those things where
um
they in addition to having all this
gluten issues and the celiac disease
um they all have the same series
of diseases and obviously opposed to the
skull and ms
everything from
um
atrial fibrillation which is not a heart
disease it's a squeezing of the 10th
cranial nerve
all of the peripheral neuropathies and
the arms and the legs and the back and
the hips and the knees and so forth the
skin
all these things are found in both
osteoporosis of the skull and also in ms
so when you start putting one on top of
the other and looking at them they're
the same disease
and so um just like i got rid of
sediment death syndrome cystic fibrosis
i have to tell you a little bit on
cystic fibrosis really quickly
um
jerry lewis and the telethon went on for
50 years more than 50 years he and the
telethon jerry lewis and telethon raised
2.7 billion dollars for the
massachusetts association
i gave jerry lewis through one of our
great marines who lives and works in
idaho and utah
okay
um
and um
is this marine okay
uh took these 12 charts to jerry lewis
where the doctors had signed off saying
they don't have musculus anymore um it's
going we don't know why but it's gone
that's because we're giving them
the nutrients okay
and um
so we shared all this for jerry lewis he
took it to the musculoskeletal
association
and he you know went with our marine
marvin robb and um
they the most physically association
shut down the telethon after 50 years
and fired jerry lewis
because he said all the evidence here
shows that
musculoskeley is not genetic as we've
been thinking it's simple nutritional
deficiencies we can cure it in two weeks
and they fired jerry lewis and shut down
the telethon
and so what do you think of the
massachusetts association now
okay these are the sort of things i've
been dealing with in battling
since 1977
and so
i'm sorry
um
dr
uh carmel harrington you are not the
discoverer of the cause
of son of a death syndrome i am
okay over to you
all right doctor wildlife and then of
course hell's kitchen
yes well that hell's kitchen tells why
we're in trouble here that's the name of
a district in new york city where every
bad thing in the world happens and you
know from crime to you name it um there
in that part of new york city so it's
called hell's kitchen so i use that name
because at three o'clock in the
afternoon monday september 4th 1882 on
pearl street in new york city in the
bluff overlooking the construction the
brooklyn bridge thomas edison pulled the
switch in the first commercial electric
generating plant within 18 years by 1900
just about everybody in america was
using electricity and very few people
had wood stoves anymore
and
when we were using wood stoves for
thousands of years and fireplaces and
fire pits
the wood ashes which are 98 minerals
and two or three percent carbon were
used as fertilizer in the gardens and
the vegetables would suck up the
minerals we'd eat the vegetables to get
milk that way a grandma would always put
wood ashes into our soups and stews and
mashed potatoes and everything else
anything that was semi liquid or liquid
she'd put the wood ashes in we're
getting minerals directly that way
when we went to electricity guess what
no more wood ashes and that's when all
of our diseases started popping up and
doctors said well all these new diseases
these 45 new diseases are what oh
they're genetic because that was the new
darling of the medical
profession was genetics
and so they blamed all these nutritional
deficience diseases on genetics
and so they missed it by
a million miles
and caused so much heartache and misery
and expense uh shortened people's lives
and doctors are not the ones that ask
how to live a long healthy life
their average life expectancy depending
on what what specialty they're in ranges
from 54 to 57.
uh the american life expectancy is 75.
the japanese life expectancy is 84.7
okay
um and when you look at um
um for the populations in big cities
the black part of the population their
life expectancy is 61-69
the whites and the hispanics
is 73 to 75 and the asians
are 86 and 91. it's not a racial thing
it's not a genetic thing it's a dietary
thing
asians
for the most part there's some who do
but for the most part asians eat rice
rather than wheat broth around oats
asians eat a lot of seaweed a lot of
trace minerals in there and so that's
why they live longer
and you have an asian who just lives
like somebody from the united kingdom or
canada or in america just eat wheat
brother and oats they're gonna die at 75
just like us
okay rebecca over to you
and then black jeans lies
okay black gene lies there are no jack
diseases in anybody even black folks so
all the diseases were
the black population has a very high
rate of death from high blood pressure
diabetes obesity heart disease cancer
they're all just simple nutritional
deficiencies and i i
proved that and demonstrated that
throughout the book here and this book
was written at the behest of pastor
krevelo dollar from atlanta georgia
he had a daughter who when the baby was
born the doctors told him
um
your daughter won't live past 12 because
she's got this terrible autoimmune
disease and she could die tomorrow but
she's certainly not going to live past
12 because everybody with this disease
dies before 12.
and so he calls me when she's about
uh 11 and a half years old only got a
couple of months to live she's very very
sick
so we got her on the program of the
ninety essential nutrients got her off
all the bad foods and of course now it's
um like 25 30 years later she's giving
him several beautiful grandchildren and
she's still alive and going but the
doctors who said she'd die at age 12
they're all dead
okay he said you got to put all this
into a book wallet i just i've been so
surprised that nobody from
um
blm black lives matter nobody has taken
this book
and gone crazy with it they should be
going crazy with this because it proves
that there's no terrible genetic
diseases in the black population
okay it supports their position but i i
don't see any activity from blm with
this book
black gene lies so i'm throwing that
invitation out there you buy 10 or more
of them you get a huge discount
and so now this is something that every
black person in the world regardless of
what countries they're from uh this
should be on their kitchen table and the
pages should be read out of that to
their kids and spouses and grandmas and
and children
um every day
and how about this one dr wallach let's
play doctor okay let's play doctor
okay well the purpose of that was
so many things are so easily dealt with
yourself and doctors are just going to
put you on a drug like prednisone or
cortisone relieve symptoms
they're not going to get rid of disease
type 2 diabetes is not a genetic disease
i can take somebody who's been a type 2
diabetic for 45 years and 2-6 weeks and
won't be a diabetic anymore because it's
a simple nutritional deficiency disease
all this is in in the book it tells you
and that's why also the book came out
rare earth's been cures as you showed
earlier
and a hair analysis chapter 10
tells you whether you're absorbing
nutrition or not the hair analysis will
tell you because if all the minerals are
down below the bottom line you're not
absorbing okay and then it tells you if
you have toxic minerals people always
say yeah you know i was in the military
and i'm sure i got all these toxic
metals and everything you know lead and
mercury and uranium and everything well
there's a second table there's a second
chart in there that goes into all the
toxic minerals and you'll see if you
have any of these toxic metals instead
of just sitting there at the bar
drinking whiskey and saying yeah i got
all these toxic minerals in me
check it out
okay
and it'll add 25 to 50 years of your
life by getting those two books right
there
let's play doctor uh goes into highway
pressure diabetes obesity
arthritis oh
osteoporosis
thyroid issues dental problems ringing
in the ears memory problems all these
things
and also prevent birth defects
okay remember
birth defects are one of the biggest
causes for the need for abortions uh
there's nothing worse than having an
embryo when it's checked out with a scan
at two and a half three months of
gestation when the baby's all harmed
they got four six eight ten different
serious life-threatening birth defects
and the parents are both in their 20s
that's not a good combination
okay well let's say the baby's perfect
but they're in their 20s they don't have
much of a future neither of them have a
a
college degree uh it's it's kind of like
right now with a pandemic and
businesses are shutting down nobody can
get a job
well when the baby's born
uh there's so many couples that can't
have kids
for one reason or another
okay they can actually
uh adopt that baby out the baby would be
happy the other couple will be happy and
they'll be happy so you know those are
some options that people consider but
let's play doctor and rare husband cures
those two books can add 25 to 50 healthy
years of your life if you follow
what you learned from there
well and dr well i
i love this picture
of you and dr ma la and your wife the
two of you have done some amazing
work
and putting this information together
that is accessible
to everybody
everybody
okay well she's a very interesting
person
um
she's very shy very quiet and she
doesn't like to be
appointed to but any rate she spent 10
years in prison in china okay because
she was working with american
hospitals and things like that
um
she
she also spent 10 years in the military
in china so there's two opposite things
one she's in the military in china also
she was in jail in china that hard labor
okay because she's cooperating with
medical doctors from america
and um but she is a a great great
scientist a great athlete she played
basketball um when she was in the in the
military for china in addition to doing
military work she played basketball for
them for the chinese military
she's six foot tall and emily five foot
six so that's why we're sitting down
[Laughter]
so she doesn't look a foot taller than
me
but she but she is a great scientist and
so she has been really really uh as you
point out an asset in in getting
uh these uh books
uh so that every sentence in there is
credible and correct so she is the
referee she's the one to make sure she
does a lot of the
um which i say
time and now it's easier because she can
sit in her office and do all all the
um chasing things down uh to to confirm
what i'm saying but before then she had
to run to this library that library this
library that library and so so now with
all the electronics she's able to just
do it from her office but thank you
yeah she's awesome and one that's not
heard about very often
god bless america
mm-hmm
god bless america of course i spent
seven years in the army and 20 years in
the air force retired as lieutenant
colonel in the air force
and
america has got to be one of the if not
the greatest country on earth
for opportunity for everybody and
helping to protect the world
and
it's one of those things where
america has done so much
for humanity
america has done so much for the earth
uh
america has done so much
for
various countries
okay we have helped so many countries
over the years and so it's one of those
things where i'm just so so proud to be
an american
and of course we have a book wall street
for kids that teaches kids how to do the
youngest business and if you can teach a
sixth grader to do this business any
adult can do this even if you only have
a sixth grade sixth grade education
if you can read sixth grade reading
level you can get that book um
wallet street not wall street but wallet
street for kids
okay
and um it will
uh lead you through
the business part of this uh and and
show these kids how to advertise and how
to
get the boy scouts and the cub scouts
and the girl scouts and the brownies get
them sponsored and they tend to be
sponsored by churches and small
businesses and schools
and so forth
get them involved and they they get all
these badges for doing things and they
will get this information out there they
will build huge businesses so they can
buy a car by the time they're 16.
they'll build a huge business so they
can pay for their own college education
they don't have to get a grant because
they'll be paying for it themselves all
because they become
a younger associate so don't forget the
boy scouts the cub scouts the girl
scouts and the brownies
they are an army
which saved america during the first
world war they're an army that saved
america during the second world war when
we're sending all our young men and
women overseas guess who kept the
country going uh the boy scouts and the
girl scouts the cub scouts and and the
brownies
okay over to you rebecca all right thank
you so much dr wilek that's just a few
of your many many books the most popular
ones you can find at askdoclive.com
you will find a menu option there that
says dr wallace books and for the ones
that you don't find there
go to drjwalic.com
and wallet is w a l l a
c
h
that's d
r j wallick.com
now dr wallach
you have done so much
and the fact that you are 83 years old
still going strong
and taking so many hours of your day
not alone the fact that you learned
technology so that you can do it
it's very commendable thank you thank
you thank you for teaching me
we're all learning because it changes as
soon as we've got it figured out
well let's get to some of our first
hands dr wallach that are
and wanting to ask you questions
the first one we have on with us today
is debbie
debbie go ahead and let me get you
go ahead and unmute yourself you're on
live with dr wallach debbie good morning
good morning good morning dr wallach
good morning
where are you from i am from spokane
washington okay and how old are you i am
67.
okay and how tall are you yeah it's not
me i'm calling about okay um i'm talking
about my husband okay 65. he is six feet
tall and he weighs 270
and he was recently diagnosed with what
looks like gliomatosis cerebri
he's been on the healthy brain and heart
pact for the past two years
i understand that one of the uh
treatment options may be whole brain
maybe brain radiation so my questions to
you are keeping him on the healthy brain
and heart pack what else nutritionally
would you recommend for him
okay stop there for a moment um
i want to know what symptoms do they
have does he have ringing in the ears
any tinnitus they ring in the ears no
his main symptom was aphasia
okay which is a memory issue it's kind
of a variation on alzheimer's disease
well there's a there's a mass there's a
brain mass at broca's area
that looks like it's a uh glioma
okay
and so um does he have any other issues
does he did he ever have bell's palsy or
wants to have his face drooped no he
hasn't no logic nothing or logic he's
had hypertension and some uh sleep apnea
okay any diabetes
no
okay any back problems no
any hip or knee problems
no
okay any dental problems receding gums
uh
yeah that was one issue
uh he had a little periodontal disease
and he had one tooth extracted
okay
yeah okay so he's got osteoporosis to
the skull
okay that's the reason why he's got
um
dental problems your jaw is part of your
skull the upper arcade your teeth and
your
skull and then of course the jaw uh
sometimes you get tmj and that kind of
stuff
and does he have anything going on any
tingling or numbness in his hands or
fingers or toes any skin plums any skin
plums any eggs in the dermatitis or
psoriasis he has vitiligo
oh okay
okay that tells me does he have gray or
white or silver hair
yes
okay yeah those are both caused by the
same deficiency
either genetic neither of them are due
to age those are both yes very good
okay
and so um
two things got to go on here
the odds are he has osteoporosis skull
the odds are
he has all this other stuff going on
because he's not only deficient in
copper but he's deficient in probably 10
or 12 other nutrients okay how many eggs
a day does he eat
not that many
is he on statin drugs no
okay well aphasia okay
again is a memory issue that's one of
the one of the variations on alzheimer's
disease
no dr walaki's got a glioma over broca's
area
i know
but that's the doctor's diagnosis you
know how many times doctors are wrong
but you tell me a lot
okay yeah well the autopsy rooms are
filled with people who die because the
doctors missed the diagnosis i get it
that's why i'm talking to you and that's
why we're 90.
okay okay well don't keep throwing the
doctor's diagnosis at me
okay
so anyway
um 270 pounds and how tall is he again
six feet six feet okay yeah i'd like to
see him weigh 200
to 10 so he's 50 60 70 pounds overweight
okay so i'm going to have one meal a day
our keto shake it's not it's not to add
to a meal it's a meal replacer so
instead of having lunch he's going to
have a keto meal instead of having
breakfast he can have keto it doesn't
have it doesn't have to be the same meal
every day
okay but one meal a day keto meal
becomes a strawberry and chocolate
he can have at that same meal with the
keto shake he can have uh one or two of
our rebounder sports drinks with a
hundred nutrients in it it's not like
red bull which is caffeine and sugar
which is an energy drink our sports
drink is a nutrition drink 75 minerals
and 25 items amino acids okay
then he needs three eggs twice a day
with soft yolks three eggs twice a day
with soft yolks absolutely no statin
drugs okay
um
all these brain things have to do with
a cholesterol deficiency a cholesterol
deficiency because 75 of the brain
weight is a
cholesterol
you have cells all over your body that
make
um
cholesterol okay from essential fatty
acids
so then i want him to get rid of all the
bad foods so he can absorb this stuff no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat no brow right notes
no sugar
there are no such things as gluten-free
oats
the gluten and oats is called gliadin
even the dietary soft drinks
the carbonation in there will neutralize
stomach acid so you cannot absorb
minerals and digest food so the diet
one's got to go
then i want them to have an msm
take three at breakfast street lunch at
dinner time that's two bottles a month
the msm they're designed to support and
promote mainstream pair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone makes
the bone itself
okay
uh also the walls of arteries and walls
of veins skin all that kind of stuff
then he also needs to take the collagen
peptides take a scoop of that with his
morning drink and a scoop of that
collagen peptides with the
evening drink
and then let's see here i also want to
have our memory fx because of the
aphasia take our memory fx take three of
those twice a day
and also he needs synaptic take three of
those twice it asynaptiv it gives the
the brain cells the biochemistry that
they need to make the chemistry to talk
to their neighbor cells and so memory
comes back
okay and the cholesterol in the eggs is
a good thing not a bad thing if you have
a doctor that just keeps ramping on him
for that then find another doctor you
know the phone book's full of doctors
but give us a call every couple of weeks
because you are going to have a great
story you're going to have a great story
and then don't forget
um you need to get a hold
of this book
that's all in your head
okay it goes into the 12 pairs of
cranial nerves
it goes into the
spinal cord and all the symptoms and
diseases you get when you have
osteoporosis of the skull
and then of course we're adding to that
rebecca and i are working on adding ms
to another chapter in this book multiple
sclerosis
and so um give us call every couple of
weeks get that book it's all in your
head and you'll be
just like flabbergasted
the information you get out of there
that'll be useful for your husband
okay
thank you you're very welcome okay
rebecca all right debbie thank you
let's just move right along dr wallach
and emily go ahead and unmute yourself
you're on live with doc dr wallach
hi dr wallach hi emily how can we help
you all right so i am actually pretty
new to youngevity um
and i came to rebecca and rhonda
um because i am
not in a good place um i've been through
a lot of trauma and
gained a lot of weight
um and now
i am five eight
sorry five eight
how much you weigh 271.
okay and how old are you
i am 32 i'll be 33 here in a month well
congratulations
thank you
okay so uh what can we we can help you
with the weight thing very quickly
that's not a problem what else you got
uh my doctor is trying to put me on
centroid which i do not want to take
okay
tell me about your thyroid my thyroid is
at a level seven right now he's saying
um and then he tried to put me on that
foreman for appetite which i told him no
um i don't want to be on anything um
yeah well he doesn't understand what
causes weight gain
okay weight gain is caused by a behavior
called pica p-i-c-a have you ever heard
of pica
no
you ever heard of cribbing
that's when horses see the top rail
of this
stall gate you know they're they're
missing minerals and so they're chewing
that on that rail because there's sweat
on it from the farmer's sweaty hand
opening the gate so they're tuned on
that top rail it's called cribbing why
do they call it cribbing because when
babies are nutritionally deficient
they chew on the top rail of the crib
oh okay yeah
that's where they came from okay
because they like that salty taste when
they're minerally deficient
okay now when you're minerally deficient
you get this term called pica you can
look it up in any dictionary p-i-c-a
okay and you eat and you eat and you eat
and you eat you eat
if you're not getting the minerals you
just keep eating and that's why you gain
weight so you take the minerals
the pica goes away and suddenly now
you're losing a half a pound of two
pounds a day
right
okay any other issues any high blood
pressure any diabetes
what just happened
no nothing nothing other than that
um
i have been taking
a lot of the stuff and i've been having
a lot of body pains today but
um rhonda explained to me that might
just be detox
okay stop
do you have anything in your joints any
knees or hips or shoulders
uh yeah so i've been battling tmj
uh yeah you have osteoporosis to the
skull tmj
you have dental problems do you have
implants or dentures or anything like
that no i have beautiful teeth but my
gums are sensitive okay so and they're
receding maybe
yeah
yeah okay yeah you have obviously
approached the skull your skull is
as
they say
everything attached to us going south
okay
and then
um let's see here what about your bowels
you have constipation diarrhea irritable
syndrome celiac disease appendicitis did
you have your panics out when you're a
kid okay
okay good
all right okay well here we go
i want you to get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no wheat broth rhinos
there are no such things as gluten-free
oats
no sugar no carbonated drinks even the
diet one's got to go because the the
carbonated water and the diet drinks
neutralize stomach acids so you cannot
absorb minerals and digest food
then
i want you to take two healthy brain and
heart packs for months you could take
three if if finances are not an issue
but don't take less than two healthy
brain and hard packs per month uh take a
full dose of everything twice a day if
you can afford three take a full dose of
breakfast lunch and dinner um you get
down to 200 pounds you can cut it down
to twice a day but right now don't go
lower than twice a day okay
and then i want you to get the two miles
a month of our msm
and i should tell you that those healthy
branded heart packs has 215 nutrients in
there
okay
so
you just can't go take you know one a
day and pull off the same
thing you still have that pica okay okay
and okay and so then you need in
addition to the two healthy brain heart
packs the two bottles a month of the msm
so you can take three with each meal i
also want you to get the collagen
peptides take a scoop of that in your
morning drink and scoop without your
evening drink i also
want you to have one meal
a day is this is a meal replacer it's
not to add to a meal it's a meal
replacer our keto shake okay it comes
either strawberry or chocolate
and um yeah and the meal that you have
your keto shake you can have one or two
of the rebound or shrinks with a hundred
nutrients in it it's not like
red bull with sugar and
caffeine
um and so we're dealing with the joints
the tmj we're dealing with your joints
and your fingers your knees your hips
and all that kind of stuff and back
did you get up at night to urinate uh
once or twice or three times
no i mean no
but i've been peeing more but no
okay not at night
okay but you peed more during the day
yeah yeah okay yeah that's because your
back is squeezing
the sciatic nerves that are formed in
the spinal cord and go to um
uh tell your urinary bladder what to do
okay
then that's why you're peeing more
because those nerves are being squeezed
they're saying p p p p
every time i get a squeeze every time
you bend over or twist or something like
that and put pressure on that nerve
it'll tell you to go take a pee make
sense yeah
okay
and so you lose a half a pound of two
pounds a day and so we've covered this
oh the thyroid
i want you to take the two things for
your thyroid one is our ocean's gold
take three twice a day that's the
seaweed from one ocean
okay and uh all kinds of seaweed and sea
cucumbers and all kind of stuff plus the
the minerals from the ocean
um that'll be two bottles a month
uh take uh three at breakfast street
dinner time and then i also want you to
take a few quid see it's from the other
ocean
okay and what is that called
a
c f u c o i d
z as in zebra
okay is that the z radical okay the z
radical is the liquid if you prefer the
liquid just get two quarts of the liquid
take an ounce of breakfast out to dinner
time you're gonna use the capsules take
three twice a day it'll be two vowels a
month yeah they're the same formula just
one's a liquid one's a capsule when i'm
at home i drink the liquid when i'm on
the road i take the capsules because i
don't want to pay the overweight
money
for you know for the right
it
okay
okay so you're gonna have a great story
emily so please please please do call us
um um you know every couple of weeks
even if you've only lost a half a pound
but i think you're going to do better
than that i think you are going to do
well yeah but look up the word pica
p-i-c-a
i'm going to that's a pika and look at
pica and look up cribbing
okay
that's me because i was a like i used to
bite my nails as a kid all the time
you were merely deficient
okay
awesome thank you doctor okay god bless
you dear you too
thank you emily
thanks
all right dr wallach
let's go ahead and and i just want to
remind everybody
thank you
so much for being on with us but as a
thank you to the person that invited you
to watch this program get back with them
if you have questions about how to
purchase the products
because these are something
are like none other none other doctor
walling the formulations that you have
put together that your team have put
together
i mean i was a supplement taker all my
life and never felt what i feel now
yeah and you had you had all kinds of
issues i had a lot of issues yeah and so
you've been able to get rid of most of
them very quickly and because you're
dedicated and when you get on
a program you do it uh you don't fluff
off you don't cheat and fudge so
and that's why you've had such great
success
and so
you are
uh
an icon and you're only what
30 years old
i love you
i love you too dear i turned 51 this
month so 51. oh that's that's a mere
child
that's right
50 is the new 20s folks
there you go
the goal here the goal here is add 25 to
50 health years everybody's life to
spend 25 to 50 health years with the
people you love
um
and you'll add 25 to 50
more healthful years your life so you
can do the things you love to do
and it's going to cost you
a few bucks a day
but it's cheaper
okay is cheaper
than
dying 50 years early
okay
and so it depends on how many issues you
have
and you know you can get away with less
than 200 bucks a month
okay
um
for an adult
um when you have like six to ten
different diseases it might cost you
um might cost you 300 or 400 bucks a
month depending what disease you have
and then when you get rid of those
disease you go down to the basic program
you're down to 200 once again okay
and so
to to add and if you do this as a
business
those costs for your for your program
for your essential factors as we say
are
tax deductible you get to tax
deduct whatever percentage you're using
in your home for your young duty
business if it's fifty percent of your
floor space for easy calculation fifty
percent and your mortgage or your rent
is uh two thousand dollars a month you
get to deduct a thousand dollars a month
that's twelve thousand dollar deduction
your taxes right there
you get to deduct the same percentage
off your utilities electricity water
um any other utilities you might have
okay uh sewer that kind of stuff
whatever you're paying utilities
and then uh you know also you get deduct
that much on people who come to clean
the house mow the lawn those kinds of
things
and it's it's what can i say
uh you can be deducting you know
anywhere from
um
12 000 and fifteen thousand dollars
a year off your taxes because you have a
young giving business plus you have a
cash income
uh that's going to help you
um put your kids through college your
grandkids or college buy a little better
car
um you know be able to buy things like
um
the
you know
the um what do you call the stuff you
put on your roof to get the sunshine to
make electricity those solar panels but
you know
yeah you know what i like the most dr dr
well one i love my car bonuses but two
i'm able to help others
yeah and that's a big thing
you go to sleep at night feeling well
because you i helped three new people
today kind of thing and uh
that's that's a god's
uh which i say that's a god's thing that
you're helping other people
and you're gonna be rewarded for it we
will reward you for doing that
yeah well and
when i started this business
i
i was i
i was so sick and i think the sicker
people
are
they're a sponge you give the body
nutrition it just wants to soak it all
up
and so i got fast results and when i
went to reorder i found out that there
was a business it was only 30 to get
started in the business i was already
going to be buying products for the rest
of my life because like tam me put in
the chat here she says i took
supplements my whole life but never got
the results i got with youngevity and
that's me
i mean
and i was
talking with somebody yesterday
for migraines they were getting botox
shots
in
their skull and i'm like
you don't have to do that
that's one of the first things that went
away from me were the migraines that i
had been living with since i was eight
years old
it's so oh my gosh
health is simple and it's simple because
you put those formulas together that
actually work that the body
needs absorbs and puts together well as
you point out rebecca the body needs all
90 60 minerals 16 vitamins amino acids
and you're not going to get it from a
one-a-day thing from the from the
pharmacy or the grocery store
um those are minimal things it's kind of
like would you put dirt in your oil pan
or your car instead of oil you could
save a lot of money it only cost you 10
cents a quart for the dirt why would you
spend three dollars a quart for the oil
well if you want your car to go 300 000
miles you better be putting oil in your
car instead of dirt from texas
yeah and folks
you are worth
investing in that extra mile
because for me
that 300 a month
was less than what i was paying to go to
see doctors
wow a week
so
it's so worth it
it's so and the fact that you can feel
great and
wake up every morning and enjoy the fact
that you are not dealing with
a whole medicine cabinet of chemicals
is incredible
well
dr wallach let's go ahead and take a
break
at the top of the hour already
everybody
thank you so much for joining us here on
ask doc live
we just want to make sure that you get
back with the person that invited you to
this program
and tell them that hey i heard dr
wallach he was talking with somebody
they had some of the same symptoms that
i'm experiencing
i want what he recommended get with that
person invited you to this program and
get on a program
that you can feel the difference
we will be right back with ask doc live
and we are back with a stock live thank
you everybody for hanging out with us
every week
and for
sharing this replay you can find the
replay at askdoclive.com
where we have all of the products that
dr wallach is talking about today and
also his most popular books
if you are not working with somebody
specifically if you have not been
introduced to youngevity or dr wallach
by a friend or somebody that you know
personally
and you would like to speak with
somebody
about what you need
for meeting your nutritional needs to
have an optimal life
we do have a contact us on the
afstocklive.com
yeah just want to make sure i ever said
that right ask.com
website where you can use that contact
us and one of our certified holistic
health coaches will get back with you
and help you get what you need to have
an optimal life
well dr wallach let's go ahead and
continue we have several hands that are
up okay
let's go with
deborah
debra go ahead and unmute yourself
you're on live with dr wallach
hi dr wallach hi deborah how can we help
you
uh i have a client that is um
uh she's 238 pounds
she's five feet two inches
she's female she's 76 years old
she has high blood pressure diabetes
arthritis bad hip pain
hair loss
gray hair she has asthma
and she does not eat three meals a day
she barely eats one or two meals a day
and she's been on the protocol but she
she she doesn't have a meal that she can
replace because she's not even eating
enough so i'm not sure how to help
somebody who doesn't eat three meals a
day with a meal replacement
okay
um well she needs one meal a day the
meal replacement
okay so she's gonna need two meals a day
minimum
okay one meal replacement which is a
keto
shake right it's not an add-on it's a by
itself with say two
of the rebound
sports drinks which has 100 nutrients in
them
then
she may have an absorption problem so
she needs to really review her household
is she the only one that lives in the
house does she have a spouse does she
have
grandkids that she has a dog and a cat
and she needs to make sure
you know i get people all the time i say
are you eating gluten no i am drunk dead
gluten-free okay what about everybody
else well i can't get them to stop
eating gluten and i have to make their
food for them so i'm making gluten okay
so they're they're wallowing in gluten
up to their neck
and that's why they can't absorb
nutrients
they gotta be gluten free okay and if
the family won't do it she's gotta move
out they gotta move out some something's
got a drastic happen here
okay
at um five foot two i want her to weigh
100 pounds 105 pounds so she needs to
lose 130 pounds
okay she needs one meal a day not two
one meal a day it's a meal replacer it's
not to add on to a meal it's a meal
replacer that keto
shake and it's um either strawberry or
chocolate
then i also want her to have
let's see here
um two healthy brain and heart packs for
months two healthy branded heart packs
per month a full dose of everything at
breakfast
and dinner
then i want her to have two bottles a
month of the msm that's going to help
with her joints and her bones and
so forth and her back and so on
um also her asthma will go away very
quickly but she's got to get off the
gluten so she can absorb the nutrition
and then um she needs uh let's say say
she needs the msm three at breakfast
street lunch for dinner time uh then she
needs the collagen peptides she can take
one of the big canisters put a scoop in
her morning drink scoop in her evening
drink
and then
which could be
a you know one of the rebounds or just
water whichever way she wants to do it
for her high blood pressure she needs to
get
i started out with two two bottles a
month of the ultimate daily classic
tablets take three at breakfast through
dinner time if she's on medication for
high blood pressure do not cold turkey
off the medication but as her blood
pressure comes down she can slowly
reduce a medication based on the numbers
the same way with diabetes in order to
get two bowels a month or sweeties if
they're back harder on the sweeties
which happens sometimes she get the
glycogenics
okay
and take
three
of the glycogenics twice a day or three
of the of the um sweeties twice a day
whichever one she can get
and
again don't cold turkey off her diabetes
medication but as the blood sugar drops
she can slowly reduce the medication
based on the numbers
and her hair color should start coming
back but if she wants to speed things up
if she's losing hair she'll use our hair
skin and nails the hair color will come
back hair loss of hair color is not due
to aging it's due to a nutritional
deficiency so it saves a lot of lab work
if i and time
and misery if i just ask the question do
you have white grayers over here because
if they say yes i already know they've
got deficiency in that nutrient okay
and people say which one is it which one
is it well i don't tell them if they get
the books they read the books they'll
tell you the reason why i don't tell
people on the radio or zooms is because
all these other people are listening and
they'll run to the grocery store or the
pharmacy they'll buy that one nutrient
they'll take that one nutrient and three
months later they're dead
because they didn't get all the other 89
they're also missing okay so i'm trying
to protect them by not telling them
which one it is come on wally tell us
which one it is no
okay so she should lose a half a pound
of two pounds a day so realistically
within uh say uh three to six months uh
she should be down
to
her 100 pounds 110 pounds
and um but she has to stay on these
nutrients okay obviously and she stays
on the nutrients it's one of those
things where
uh if she goes back to her old ways
within six months she'll start gaining
weight again it'll be the same old cycle
again
but she will add 25 to 50 health for
years her life if she does what we
tell her to do this is very simple we've
been doing this commercially for over 50
years we have a lot of experience we're
in 80 countries so it's not just
oh that just happens with people who
come from
whatever okay no this is all human
beings it doesn't matter what race you
are what gender you are how old you are
everybody requires 90 cents of nutrients
so you've got a program here for this
lady
um okay how about pressure diabetes all
the joint stuff
um
and so let's let's just go with that
let's start there
okay
thank you dr wallach
let's hear from you every couple of
weeks deborah you're gonna have a great
story
okay
back to you rebecca
all right thank you deborah
dr wallach you know in the beginning of
the program we were talking about sids
and
right now
we hear all across the news that there's
a shortage in formula
and i know you briefly mentioned it last
week but i think it's well worth
mentioning
again and i saw somebody's name who had
emailed me in a question about it
but what can we do
for our babies
one let's start with the ones that are
not being breastfed and then two let's
go ahead and move into
what mama can do to give that extra
nutrition okay very good yeah well well
kids are my favorite people okay
i've been dealing with kids health
issues forever
since i was a kid myself and so my kids
are my favorite people
and so i'm just very very much disturbed
we're america we're supposed to you know
be the best economy in the world we're
supposed to be uh have the best health
care system in the world and we can't
get baby formula for babies and remember
uh based on on my
research and work
and lawsuits against
the fda and manufacturers of baby
farmers we forced them to put these
nutrients into the baby formulas
okay
and sediment death syndrome went from
135 to 160
per hundred thousand births in america
to
15 to 20 from 1990 to now
okay
um and so
um
it's too much of a coincidence it
started going down as soon as
the lawsuits uh
were ruled in my favor and within a
couple of months they had to put those
nutrients in the baby farmers well we
have the kids toddy
um
his toddy
is a liquid
okay it tastes very good
and you know you get kids that are three
years old kids can die from son of a
death syndrome you know when they're a
year old or two years old the kids toddy
tastes good uh it's a complete
supplement except for the efas you need
the efas and i would also throw in the
cherrymans use the same
um uh dosage per pound for body weight
for the cherrymans that you do for the
kid's toddy uh one or two
of the efas per day puncture the ifas
don't puncture the kid you puncture the
efas and squirt that into the kid's body
and uh
add it
to their to goat's milk or to cow's milk
okay uh people have been using goat's
milk and cow's milk for baby farmless
for thousands of years
and so but don't forget back in those
days
we had wood ashes and so when the
mothers were giving some breast milk the
mothers were putting wood ashes into
their food they're getting the minerals
that way
and so it's one of those things where
you have to make sure that these kids
are getting their nutrition just
calories and protein is not enough
calories and protein are not enough you
need those 90 essential nutrients
and so we have a system to do that it's
unimpeachable
we've been doing it gosh
since those court cases go back
to the 1990s
we've
sued them 12 times
the fda and the baby farm manufacturers
and we won
nine times
okay and so this is unimpeachable
evidence
court records
federal court records these are
unimpeachable records and so we as you
point out we have
put together stuff that will
prevent these babies from dying from
sids from getting muscular dystrophy now
where did i learn that well i learned it
from turkeys
i learned from turkeys because turkeys
were dying of sudden death syndrome
okay which is hypertrophy cardiomyopathy
heart disease
and they put that one nutrient in the
turkey formulas and all the turkeys
stopped dying of hypertrophic
carbohydrate heart disease so we learned
that in turkeys
in in the 1950s
and that's that's when all this started
happening in my mind saying okay i got
it
so we got to do the same thing for
people
and so my background in agriculture my
background in veterinary medicine my
background as a pathologist
then as a physician
excuse me
and then there's dealing with a
lecture in public health
being a a teacher and a professor
uh in um
in the naturopathic colleges in portland
oregon
i'm licensed in oregon i'm licensed in
california as a doctor naturopathic
doctor
and
it's one of those things where
i learn something every day
i help thousands of people every hour
because i work in 80 countries and we do
all these zooms in all this country like
this even i'm going to be and
let's see here i'm going to be in
australia we're going to go through
a dr carmel
harrington we're going to go through her
story again so she's from australia
we'll go through that one again
tonight yesterday i was in the
philippines
okay
and and then i'll be in japan and i'll
be in the uk i'll be in canada i'm all
over the place
and you know some of these
um
facebook is sending my
zooms out to 800 people a thousand
people
when they like it you know on this stuff
right now with this uh covered 19 i like
my stuff they like my stuff when it came
to the baby followers they're sending
out eight hundred thousand
um people on facebook
and so we're getting the message out
there and so i can't thank you enough
rebecca and uh
george nori and his team and all your
team there
for getting this message out and helping
so many people
uh and this is what it takes if you're
doing you and your team are doing god's
work
and so this is why it's being so
successful because it's god's stuff
we'll give the good lord all the credit
well dr wellick it's our pleasure to be
able to share this message with others i
know it is for me nasima's been with the
company a long time ruth allen's been
with the company a long time so i'm
sure if it wasn't a pleasure for them
they wouldn't be doing it
dr judy with her experience with a
doctorate in nutrition
she's heard about you and she's like i
don't know why i didn't hear about him
sooner i even lived in the same state
um so she's very thankful for all the
work that you have done so she's a
missouri girl
she's a missouri well that's where she
lives
that's where she lives
from missouri but that's where she's
been living for quite a while
okay
so there's many of us that are so
thankful for you dr wally
let's go to the next hand that it is up
and carrie if you can turn your
camera on that would be fabulous
and unmute you
are on live with dr wallach is that
carrie
carey yes
hello kerry
yes how can we help you yes how can we
help you
um
good to see you again dr wallach um i
have a person i wrote in about and um
rebecca responded and gave me
uh good information so i have somebody
that's been on the products and they do
have a success story because they had
high blood pressure
uh and a stroke in uh july of last year
and i pretty much told them you either
go on this stuff
and do it 110 percent or we know where
the medications will take you because
he'd already been on
um blood pressure medications calcium
channel blockers
and
diabetes medications so we did the
just what i understood at the time i was
a newbie i still am a newbie um healthy
body start pack selenium sweeties blah
blah blah all his numbers came down
within three months all he was graduated
from their monitoring program
but he has diabetic retinopathy and he's
getting shots in the eyes and i was just
wondering if you could explain that a
little bit because the doctors are very
curt when we ask questions they're very
um
you know resistant to say that you have
this percentage or that percentage of
improvement
they
they won't give us a scale of how bad is
this thing that we're dealing with
because they don't know anything about
it that's because they don't know
anything about it
they don't want to show their ignorance
so when they get curt with you that
means i don't know anything about this
don't ask me
yeah they wave their hands and go oh i
can't tell you you know that's because
they don't know
okay
so when you have diabetic retinopathy of
the eyes how old is this person
54.
yeah the odds are this person has
osteoporosis of the skull squeezing the
optic nerve the optic artery the optic
vein
okay
retinopathy the retina is the lining
of the inside of the eye
okay
when you have inflammation of that
uh it has to do with osteoporosis of the
skull squeezing the optic nerve the
optic or the optic vein the pressure in
the eye can go up
okay
you get all kinds of stuff
and so
um
basically uh you don't just get high
blood pressure
of the heart
you get high blood pressure of the eye
the brain all these kinds of things
so
um again
for other viewers and listeners
um you need to get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no wheat powder
around those so sugar no carbon or
drinks
absolutely none of that stuff
um then two healthy brain and heart
packs per month two healthy brain and
heart patterns because of the stroke and
the
and the high blood pressure and all that
kind of stuff
uh the two bottles a month of the msm so
you take three at breakfast lunch for
dinner time uh don't forget the ultimate
daily classic tablets three twice a day
that's two bottles a month to support
healthy blood pressure and healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries and then
sweeties um two bottles a month of that
thing take three breakfast three dinner
time don't cold turkey off either
medications either for the blood
pressure or the diabetes
but as the blood pressure drops you can
lower the medication
uh when you when your diabetes blood
sugar begins to go down you can lower
the medication based on the numbers
okay
and for anti
inflammation and support the immune
system
you want to use the
fucoid see
which is seaweed from one ocean
okay if you prefer the liquid if they
prefer the liquid they could use the z
radicals the same formula just one's
liquid ones uh
uh pills if you're going to take the
pills capsules
take three twice a day there's two
vowels a month if you're going to use
the liquid take two quarts a month take
an ounce of breakfast sounds to dinner
time
and that retinopathy will go away
okay
yeah
what do the shots do
they send the doctor's kid to college
okay they're very damaging i feel they
the eye swells up it's yeah see you have
to appreciate the shots they're probably
cortisone or prednisone just
anti-inflammatory stuff they're treating
symptoms
right this is this is very typical of 99
percent of doctor therapies treat
symptoms
just like ms multiple sclerosis
billion dollars a year in america just
to treat the symptoms of ms multiple
sclerosis 85 billion with a b
that's about as criminal as you can get
okay and so we're working on that one uh
rebecca and i are working on that we're
going to get the information out there
we're going to get all these people off
all these medications for
for ms
because i believe it's kind of a
duplicate of osteoporosis skull when you
look at all of the signs and symptoms
and diseases that are associated with
osteoporosis skull they're all the same
signs symptoms and diseases of ms
both of them have
a celiac disease they cannot absorb
nutrition and so it's
one part of the country diagnosed it one
way
and and uh you know
called it um
uh let's see here
called it dog barking no
uh called it
ms
and the other doctor me i'm the one
who's pointed out that osteoporosis is a
skull
12 pairs of cranial nerves and spinal
cord being squeezed by the skull when
you have osteoporosis those tunnels that
they go through are losing 75 percent of
their internal
diameter because of all the scar tissue
and that's they're being squeezed that's
why they have all these symptoms and
diseases but doctors are treating those
symptoms as an individual disease
and so there may be people
with 14 of the 25 diseases they're going
to seven specialists
okay all for osteoporosis as a scholar
for ms
terrible terrible terrible so i think
together we'll be able to solve all
these problems
does the um scar tissue reabsorb when
when people start doing the right thing
yes yeah your body like for instance the
skull is normally a quarter of an inch
thick uh when you get osteoporosis it
goes over a time over months it goes to
an inch to two inches thick that's why
all the spaces in those tunnels that the
nerves and spinal cord go through lose
75 percent of their internal volume and
that's why putting pressure on the
nerves and spinal cord well uh within
weeks
the inflammation dies down
and so they begin to relieve the
pressure on the nerves and spinal cord
and within a month or two
it's all back to the normal one quadrant
six skull
same way with your joints your knees and
your hips your shoulders and your
fingers
and your vertebrae and your disc between
your vertebrae um they come and go based
on your nutrients
right okay
okay
i appreciate your time and thank you so
much for everything dr welcome okay well
thank you for what you're doing because
you're an angel of god doing god's work
we appreciate you
i'm starting with my family and
that's the hard row
you know it can you know it can be your
own family
yeah well you know i i used to get that
when i was a kid i'm only like seven
years old and say what do you think
you're a doctor who are you you're just
a kid
yeah yeah so thank you so much thanks
for you know arming us with the tools
that we need
you're very welcome
thank you carrie
all right and uh let's just keep on
going dr wallace okay let's go for it
amy
amy go ahead and unmute yourself
bye
but don't [__] if you have a camera can
come on camera that would be fabulous
too
okay how can we help you
um sorry i had to get away from the
noise um
yeah so i'm uh
49 years old 130 pounds uh my friend
told me to call because
he said that i might be
having osteoporosis skull because i've
had tinnitus for over 10 years oh yeah
tennis tonight yep ringing into the yeah
you have osteoporosis of the skull
squeezing the auditory branch of the
eighth cranial nerve you need to get a
hold of this little book that's all in
your head
it goes through all these different
nerves and and what symptoms and what
diseases you get when they get squeezed
and the formula i'm going to give you is
in the book
okay
okay okay it's called it's all in your
head
and you can get it through
um rebecca
one way or another okay
do you have any um also in addition to
the tinnitus or tinnitus do you have any
vertigo or balance problems
um
recently yeah i stubbed my toe really
badly fractured my toes i think i lost
balance there
okay i have receding gums too
okay now what about
do you get up at night once or twice or
three or four times ago urinate
no
okay good any skin plums any eczema
dermatitis or psoriasis
yes
okay do you have any bowel problems
irritable bowel syndrome appendicitis um
celiac disease crohn's disease anything
like that
no i've been taking your sweeties for a
while
i've been taking products actually for a
while so
okay
well you gotta get rid of all the bad
foods so you can absorb maximum
absorption right
and don't forget the uh the msm
to help regrow the skull
okay rebuild the skull you need the msm
uh you get two bottles a month of that
so you can take three twice three three
times a day excuse me three breakfast
straight lines for dinner time you need
the collagen peptides get the big
canister so you can take a scoop of that
with your morning drink without your
evening drink don't forget vitamin d3
take three of those twice a day there's
two bottles a month
and you can speed things up if you want
to
by also getting our beyond osteo fx
uh you know take a couple of doses of
that a day comes in liquid capsules or
powder however you want to take it take
two doses a day is beyond osteo effects
and
uh gosh i've been doing this for 50
years
and i'm like i say 83
and it's one of those things where most
people think i'm in my 50s when they
look at me they don't they don't they
can't realize
83.
okay so anyway yeah so
um
this can be reversed or oh oh yeah oh
this is reversible
okay how long does that usually take if
i follow the protocols you told me well
if you are drop dead gluten free
to maximize absorption and follow the
protocol you should see some positive
results within anywhere from three days
to two weeks
oh wow okay
now
for complete resolution it might take
you four to six weeks depending on how
bad things are if your skull is two
inches thick it might take you you know
two months three months to get complete
resolution but you'll have clinical
results you know improvement within a
couple of days or weeks
oh great yeah you know that i'm sure you
know doctors always tell you they have
no idea why you have tinnitus
no idea well you have to remember
doctors don't know anything about
osteoporosis they think oh you have
osteoporosis of your hip we're going to
give you a hip replacement if you have
osteoporosis of the hip you have
osteoporosis of every bone and every
joint in your body including the skull
and your you know tmj and
you got
all over the place you don't just have
it in your right hip
oh
yeah right
that's just a place where it shows up
yeah
okay
do you understand
yeah okay doctors have no earthly idea
what's going on here and that's why they
fail so badly that's why their average
lifespan their average life expectancy
is 54 to 57
depending on what specialty they're in
emergency room doctors have the shortest
lifespan they live to be 54.
wow
they're not the people to ask how to
live a long healthy life
right right you get you get run over by
a truck you're bleeding internally you
got to go to the emergency room
yeah
right
okay
thank you so much so did you well tell
me exactly because you went a little
fast i was writing really quickly but
i'm sorry say that again the person on
the phone the res your other person will
tell me
what products it is because i wrote it
down but it was a little fast so okay
well it's recorded
oh okay
okay so you just come back on and you
know
it's recorded
they say they save these things forever
so you can get right to it
okay perfect thank you so much
bye-bye
amy you can go to askdoclive.com
you'll find the replay there later today
okay great thank you so much you're very
welcome thanks for coming on
thank you
now
dr wellick we have a question in the
chat here monica
five foot six
130 pounds
60 year old woman
says
has 16 point high white cell count
what can i do
i'm on no drugs
okay
she got a high white blood cell count
right that's her only complaint that's
the only complaint that she's listed
here yes
no pharmaceuticals
okay well she could have 25 different
diseases
and the doctors don't know what to do
here
okay so when you have
um
high white blood cell count it could be
chronic inflammation it could be a
chronic infection it could be athlete's
foot it could be an infected tooth
you know
an abscessed tooth it could be a lot of
anything
and it could be irritable bowel syndrome
and you know got
celiac disease because she's eaten
gluten
so these are all things that have to be
dealt with so
uh you gotta get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no we bought around
notes no sugar no carbohydrate drinks
either the diet one's got to go
there's no such thing as gluten-free
oats
and then you want to live like an asian
live on rice and sweet potatoes and
beans and squash and that kind of stuff
plus all the vegetables and of course
you eat red meat but not fried you can
eat chicken
and
duck and and turkey but not fried
roasted is fine
fish
not fried okay roasted is fine or boiled
or stewed or even raw sashimi okay
then at 130 pounds i wanted to have one
healthy brain and heart pack per month
one health branded heart peppermint a
half a dozen everything twice a day get
an extra bottle of our slime so you can
take three of those twice a day
then i wanted her to have
um let's see here i'd go with two
bottles a month of the msm so you can
take three breakfast street lunch at
dinner time and they're going to support
and promote maintenance repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between the vertebrae bone
matrix which is where white blood cells
are made
okay white blood cells are made in the
bone marrow the bone matrix okay
and so um then i wanted her also to have
the collagen peptides again for the bone
marrow and the immune system i wanted to
have a scoop in her morning drink and a
scoop in her evening drink because the
collagen peptides i wanted to have
um uh let's see here
two doses a day of the beyond osteo fx
this is uh it either comes in a powder
capsules or liquid
a dose in the morning
breakfast dose in the evening dinner
and let's see here
i think
that's going to deal with the white
blood cells stuff in the bone marrow
okay
and
don't forget vitamin d3 three of those
twice a day there's two bowels a month
so you can absorb all these minerals and
put them in the right places
and let's go there and you know when you
reply to her if if she contacts you
again
um
uh be be sure to ask her more questions
because i guarantee if she's got a high
white blood cell count she's got other
things going on she just you know she's
got pain here and she's got it under
control of the pain reliever she's got
um inflammation here and she's got taken
um things like appendizone or cortisone
she's got relief and so she's not
mentioning him she got high blood
pressure because she's taking high blood
pressure medication she's got it quote
under control because that's why i asked
people all these things did she tell you
she has white gray or silver hair it's
not due to aging nutritious deficiency
and so we need more information but
we've done the best we could do with
what we had
all right thank you so much dr wellick
and let's go to one of the emails that i
had come in okay
um and the question is are there any
special nutrients that keep the teeth
from being a little bit mobile
and
what can i do to help with more or
better saliva
so the dentist wants them to have a root
canal
they
and they suddenly have started getting a
lot of cavities at 70 years old
um and they have a dry mouth
okay and the odds are
she's got loose teeth that means she's
got osteoporosis in the skull the skull
includes your jaw as well as your upper
arcaded teeth
and as the bone disappears the teeth get
loose
okay and so she got osteoporosis called
i guarantee you she's got other things
going on she might have this tinnitus
she might have vertigo balance problems
she might have arthritis in her hips and
her knees she may have had already a
double hip replacement she would she
didn't mention you understand what i'm
saying there's other things going on
other than her loose teeth and cavities
in a tooth
okay
so she needs a lot of stuff
she needs do do we know how much she
weighs no
no
okay
so let's go for 100 pounds of body
weight one healthy brain and heart pack
for 100 pounds of body weight
she needs um
one bottle a month to the msm
she needs uh let's see here one canister
the collagen peptides a scoop and a
breakfast drink a scoop of evening drink
uh she needs vitamin d3
take three breakfasts for dinnertime
that's just for a per 100 pounds of body
weight
then um i'd have also take
we do have
like five or six different types of
calcium
okay including the beyond osteo fx we
have it in liquid
capsules and pills and also in powder
and so let's start there but again
um
the the loose teeth are just the tip of
the iceberg literally okay the tip of
the iceberg there's
more deadly things going on
deeper in her skull her heart her
intestines uh we don't know anything
about her skin what's her hair color
we don't know much about this gal
otherwise she's she's just complaining
about loose teeth and cavity in a tooth
all right thank you so much let's go to
the next town that is up kenny
go ahead and unmute yourself
hi doc in here
yes kenny yeah we can hear you
oh great thanks for uh
taking my my case
uh so
i've had a lot of i'm i'm 60 i'm 5 foot
10 um 220.
i've had a lot of tests lately because
i've had a lot of symptoms and no one
can find anything so hopefully uh you
can help i'm okay tingling legs
uh
ringing in the ears and sometimes it
gets very loud i'm having some balance
problems
recently had some arthritis in my
fingers
uh and um
yeah dry skin
out of nowhere just i've had this really
bad dry skin okay give me white gray or
silver here
uh no it's it's a little bit of your
beard beard and mushrooms yes yes and
the beards yeah all of a sudden
overnight yeah it's just recently okay
okay it has nothing to do with ages it's
due to a nutritional deficiency
okay you have osteoporosis of the skull
that's what's causing the tingling and
and tinnitus the ringing in the ears and
the vertigo and balance problems as
osteoporosis of the skull
you ever had uh
bell's palsy
uh i had i had a little uh an episode
about a month ago where the right side
of my face was all tingly and i noticed
some saliva on the right side of my
mouth yeah yeah so yeah they get either
bell's palsy or trigeminal neuralgia
either one of those okay or both okay
um any high blood pressure diabetes
uh no
okay even if you got under control with
drugs i need to know it
okay
so here we go well i've been close to
that but i've i've not really been
diagnosed okay so okay well here we go i
need to get rid of all the bad foods no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat nobody around oats
there's no such thing as gluten free
oats you get rid of the sugar absolutely
no
carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go because the carbonation
neutralizes stomach acid
um which is required to absorb minerals
and digest food
then at 220 pounds i want you to have
two healthy brain and heart packs for
months two hundred excuse me two healthy
brain and heart passion a month to
photos everything twice a day i want you
to get two bottles a month of our msm so
you can take three breakfast street
lunches and ten they're large bottles
you'll be able to do that with two
bottles
and they're designed to support and
promote
um maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between the vertebrae bone makes your
bone itself including the joints in your
fingers and toes and skull and all that
kind of stuff
and then
uh i would also throw in
the vitamin d3 three of those twice a
day that's two bowels a month
uh to help absorb all these minerals and
put them in the right place need the
collagen peptides
uh get one of the large canisters to put
a scoop of that your morning drink and
scoop without your evening drink okay
and let's see here that's going to help
with the skin and the skull
uh
all this tinnitus and vertigo and
the bell's palsy and all that kind of
stuff
the tingling and numbness the skull is
squeezing the spinal cord
and so when you have the tingling in
your fingers and toes and legs and arms
um this is happening because the skull
is squeezing the spinal cord as the
spinal cord is formed in the brain most
people don't realize is they think your
spinal cord is formed in the spine no
the spinal cord is formed in the brain
comes out a big hole in the back of the
skull called foramen magnum which is
latin for big hole
okay
and um you'll lose a few pounds uh
without having to do anything just stay
away from the bad twos you'll you'll
probably get down to
maybe 190 to 200 you'll lose maybe 20
pounds
but the joint problems will go away
the tinnitus will go away the tingling
will all go away and as the doctors ever
talked to you about a possibility of ms
multiple sclerosis
i've been tested for all that and been
cleared of all that okay good okay that
means you have osteoporosis of the skull
for sure okay because um both of those
ms and osteoporosis
are the same disease
okay but what they're looking for
is severe demyelination of the brain
they do scans of the brain to see if
half your brain is gone do you have any
memory problems
aphasia
yeah i'm having yeah i'm having some
memory problems okay so i would also
throw in
okay
i would also throw in our memory effects
take three of those
twice a day memory effects and also
throw in our synaptive take three of
those twice a day to two vowels a month
and the synaptive and the memory fx
gives the brain cells what they need to
make the biochemistry to talk to their
neighbor cells
don't forget three eggs you'll need
three eggs twice a day with soft yolks
soft boils soft poached soft sauce
scrambling butter
cholesterol is a good guy cholesterol
makes up 75 of your brain weight do not
take statin drugs
i'll repeat that do not take statin
drugs
okay no i i did a long time ago and i
had an issue with it so i never doing it
again so okay good yeah don't don't go
there okay give us a call every couple
of weeks kenny because you are going to
have a great story
yes i will i have two ques two quick
questions um
i've been kind of often on gluten-free
are gluten-free products okay like
gluten-free bread and chips and things
i would just make sure there's no oats
in them now if they're
what are they made from they're made
from rice are they made from yeah a lot
of rice a lot of yeah i try to stick to
the rice products yeah yeah rice is good
see the asians do better than us
uh coming with longevity and health
because they eat rice
okay there are places in japan there's
places in china where they grow wheat
and they they have the worst health
records of anybody in china and japan
compared with the ones who live you know
where they grow rice
okay okay
it's a dietary thing
all right okay one other quick question
thank you um
what is it when i i when i eat food i
get horribly horribly tired afterwards
it's just okay
you can't have what's called reactive
hypoglycemia it's kind of a pre-diabetes
issue it's called reactive hypoglycemia
and this is why people do hit on
collisions when they're driving they do
autopsy
they do uh they can't find any drugs
well why'd they cross the center line
that's because they got sleepy while
they were driving
because they have reactive hypoglycemia
so what you want to do is get two bowels
a month also of the sweeties and take
three of those twice today and that'll
resolve that
okay it's kind of a pre-diabetes
situation it's called reactive
hypoglycemia you can look it up in any
dictionary just has siri what is
reactive hypoglycemia
okay
okay reactive hypoglycemia because you
eat your body releases a lot of insulin
and knocks your blood sugar down too low
okay and that's why you get drowsy after
you eat
okay that's good information thank you
okay but the sweeties will resolve that
okay
all right i'll all right i'll check give
it a call every couple of yeah yeah yeah
check back in because you're going to
have a great story
okay all right great thanks you bet okay
thank you kenny
all right dr wallach
let's go to one of the emails that i had
come in and this is
from lydia
so lydia is 60 years old
at five foot nine she's 140 pounds okay
she says i have extreme pain in my legs
hips spine and shoulder joints
my blood work came back all good
except my crt level is 49.
what would you recommend
crt
not quite sure what the crt is i can
find out yeah find out for me crt when
people throw abbreviations at you
um looks like it's creatinine
credentials
creatinine yes yeah okay
okay
so here we go um
she's got you know widespread
osteoporosis and arthritis not unusual
in america okay and a middle-aged woman
um women
have four times the rate of osteoporosis
as men
women have three times the rate of ms
multiple sclerosis as men
and it's because of their dietary habits
and their work habits most women work
inside
air-conditioned offices or in their
homes
where men are outside without their
shirts to get some sunlight some vitamin
d3 you know working out in the pastures
and the fields in the gardens and
washing cars
mowing lawns and working on roofs and
stuff like that so they're getting some
at least some sunshine for women
maybe they do it for
two weeks out of the year when they go
on vacation at a beach someplace okay
and so just think about it four times
the rate of osteoporosis in women as men
three times the rate of ms and women as
men
and that's it tells you the story here
it's the same disease
both
osteoporosis skull and ms multiple
sclerosis or the same disease
that's why you and i are working on this
okay
and so um
so this gal here at 140 pounds
lydia
needs to
get rid of all the bad foods no fried
foods no processed meats no oils or
gluten the wheat by ryan oates
um
absolutely um no sugar no carbonated
drinks even the diet one's got to go 140
pounds she's right on the cusp but since
she has pain in every joint in her body
i never take two healthy abandoned heart
patterns a month to full dose everything
twice a day she needs two bottles a
month of the msm so you can take three
with breakfast three with lunch with
dinner time they're going to help
rebuild cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disc between the
vertebrae bone makes bone itself she
needs vitamin d3 three of those twice a
day there's two bones a month to help
absorb the metals and put them in the
right place
cheesy collagen peptides to get the
large canister take a scoop of that in a
breakfast drink and scoop without your
evening drink
i'd also have her take the
the uh let's see here
it wouldn't hurt for because she has so
much joint stuff going on and also have
her take the glucogel ever take a couple
of large bottles of glucogen so she can
take five twice a day there's five of
directives five at dinner i take three
twice as ages for prevention i only
weigh 142 so i'm pretty close to her
body weight
and um and i don't have any joint
problems i don't have any
um bone problems i don't have any
osteoporosis i'm 83 years old i don't
have any of that stuff i don't have any
diabetes i don't have any reactive
hypoglycemia i don't have any highlight
pressure i don't have any fibromyalgia i
don't have any as i don't have any of
that stuff
okay
and i think i probably only have one
grade here in my body and it's under my
right arm okay
and so
if you do everything right you're going
to have 25 to 50 healthful years your
life
and you're going to save yourself an
enormous amount of unnecessary misery
you're going to save yourself an
enormous amount of money by doing these
things
okay
um that rebecca and i are talking about
it's one of those things where
we're this is unimpeachable information
i've been in this commercially for over
50 years i've been doing it personally
for 75 years
and
you know i'm just a dumb kid figured
this out
when doctors they had 20 doctors looking
at me when i was like
four or five six years old and they
couldn't figure out what was wrong with
me they sent me to another doctor refer
me to another doctor they're gonna put
me into an institution and turn me into
a laboratory animal and do tests on me
and i said what if they can't find out
what's wrong well you may have to stay
in that institution for the rest of your
life well that didn't sound good to me
that's when i figured it out in three
days that i just started eating animal
food and all my problems that i'd had
for
seven years went away
in three days just eating animal food
okay so that's how i figured that out
well dr wallach it's it's simply
incredible
but it all makes sense we complicate it
well we don't complicate it the doctor
is complicated okay
marketing food companies
yeah they turn they turn they turn the
population into a dairy
yeah
and that's one reason why i shop around
the outside of the grocery store
things aren't in boxes and ready to just
add water and throw in the microwave
yeah no no
you want to buy you know you want to
look at the tomatoes yourself you want
to look at the tomatoes celery
and look at corn on the cob you can buy
those there's no gluten in corn don't
fry it you can roast it bake it grill it
boil it
don't fry it
and then also rice oh my gosh
i had a big big
two cups of wild rice steamed wild rice
for breakfast this morning
along with my i had
tuna fillets
okay
i just love tuna fillets
and to have that for breakfast i also
have tomorrow for breakfast i'm going to
have instead of tuna fillets i'm going
to have wild salmon not smoked salmon
but just raw frozen wild salmon
and so
then of course i had an orange i some
mornings i'll have a tomato i'll have my
yogurt and i have all my drinks and my
um all my
supplements all my essential factors and
vitamins and minerals my pills and
capsules and drinks and everything
and it's one of those and also i like
herbal peppermint tea
for breakfast also
and so you can have a wonderful
breakfast i do not take any
pharmaceuticals
i repeat that the only time i had
pharmaceuticals was when i had my injury
i fell into
a pit that
that um
people had dug
who that i've been walking across that
field for 25 years up in canada no
problem
but they were building stuff and they
dug a trench to throw all the trash in
they didn't put any flags around it and
no lights there so i'm walking and
falling into that pit and got punctured
with all this twisted rebar
and got infections in my feet and my
legs my back so i did have to go to the
hospital for three days for intravenous
antibiotics and i wanted to cut my legs
off and said nope i'd rather die than
having don't cut my legs off just give
me intravenous antibiotics and they did
and i took all my
essential factors i kept taking those
and in a week's time i was cured of my
terrible infections where i'd been
punctured by the rebar
that's been it
that was a 20
something years ago
okay
as one of those things where
if you do everything right you're going
to save yourself an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery you're going to add
25 to 50 healthy years your life
but i do have a coffin company for
people who don't want to spend the 200
bucks a month for their supplements
um i'll give you my card and so when the
time comes if you're not taking the
supplements you're going to die early
you will need my other services
dr wilik you
do you do have a good humor
i know many of us appreciate that so
i can't believe we're coming up to the
end of the hour but we're not quite
there yet we've got time for one more we
have we have time yes we do so i have
um somebody that had texted me and they
are wanting to know dr wallach about
fatty liver disease
so i have a gentleman he's six foot one
um
225 pounds
and he's only 42.
okay
well fatty liver is not an aging thing
it's actually a nutritional deficiency
as you might expect liver does about 50
different things i mean it is a busy
organ it detoxifies stuff it produces
bile to help you digest and absorb
fat soluble vitamins and fatty acids and
and good fats and stuff like that it
stores fuel it makes antibodies
stores white blood cells
the liver is a busy busy organ
and so when you start getting fatty
liver that means it can't be doing its
job because there's something missing
and so at 225 pounds
uh this guy's got to get rid of all the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
meats no oils no glutens and wheat
products no sugar no carb in drinks even
the diet one's got to go i'd have them
take
two healthy brain and heart patch a
month to photos everything twice a day
uh get an extra bottle of selenium so i
can take three three times a day it'll
be a bottle of there's are selenium with
all the five cofactors not from
walgreens but our selenium the five
cofactors
so you can take three at breakfast field
entry dinner time then he also needs to
take the collagen peptides take a scoop
of that with his morning drink a scoop
of this evening drink
take the vitamin d3 three of those twice
a day i'd also have them take
the
um let's see here the fucoid z three of
those twice a day are the z radical same
thing with z radical as liquid take it
ounce twice a day if you're going to
take the liquid
that's going to detoxify the liver i'd
get the book rare earth's men cures get
the book rare urban cures in chapter 10
i'll tell you how to do a hair analysis
and see if there's any toxic minerals
like lead
uh mercury uranium that kind of stuff
i'm running into a lot of people with
high levels of uranium because they live
downwind
from a utility
um
facility you know makes electricity and
the fuel is oh
uranium okay and they're not doing a
good job of containing
uh the smoke and and waste and
byproducts and everything
and so it's leaking out into the
community and so there is showing up in
the hair analysis
and so doing a hair analysis
is a good thing it's going to save you a
lot of money and time to do the hair
analysis because you'll be able to tell
yourself if you got those toxic minerals
and if you do have toxic metals you have
what we call herbal rainforests that'll
detoxify them
an ounce twice a day um per 100 pounds
of body weight if you get diarrhea cut
it to a half ounce twice a day to start
with and when you get used to it you can
go back up to an ounce twice a day and
then three months later do another hair
analysis and see how much improvement
you've got if you got any improvement at
all you may have to move
if you know if that facility is still
pumping out waste
contaminated material
so any rate
yeah this is a fatty liver is an easy
one to deal with
they do have to stop all conscious
proactive toxicity meaning got to stay
away from alcohol
and they can do the rebound or sports
drink with 100 nutrients in it
for 225 pound person they could take two
or three of those a day
and um
but uh yeah
don't to drink alcohol when you have a
fatty liver
all right thank you dr wallach and gary
had a quick question here
um a-l-s
hey aim electrocute lateral sclerosis
okay that that has to do
they're they're losing the white matter
in the brain and the spinal cord
okay
and so again three eggs twice a day this
is the one we talked to earlier same
carry yes okay yeah it needs to have
three eggs twice a day with soft yolks
to add to her program
this is
soft yolks soft wild soft poached soft
soft scrambling butter hardball days
don't count she cannot be on statin
drugs
okay
and so that falls
very similar into the same category as
ms is that correct that is correct
they'll all fit into the same territory
as ms and osteoporosis of the skull i'll
see awesome thank you so much dr wallach
on behalf of myself
and my co-hosts jonathan mccollier
nasima omar ruth ellen sanchez heather
bowen and dr judy reynolds dr wallach we
just want to thank you
for coming on with us and being part of
well
allowing family
because we are family yeah we are family
we
cannot thank you and your team enough
for all that you do
uh for humanity and for america and for
the world for that matter and so i and
again i can't thank you for giving that
information
on um um dr um
uh carmel
um
harrington okay
because i'm gonna be on australia's zoom
tonight and she's from australia so i'm
gonna hit it hard again tonight
and hope she gets the message
awesome
wonderful wonderful
well everybody get back to the person
that shared this program with you
if you were not referred to this program
by any spec anybody specific you found
it all on your own or you got an email
reply back to that email
but we do have a call team that is
standing by for those who have never
ordered from youngevity before have
never spoken with a younger distributor
either that number is eight five five
nine four nine
seven
on behalf of myself rebecca dukes kozak
and the whole entire askdoc live team
and dr wallach
bye for now bye-bye love you dear
bye-bye love you too dr wallach
bye everybody bye-bye team